hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and here are
10 legendary rules from legendary
entrepreneurs do everything you can to
survive not to give up as long as you
tried everything you can then if you
fail your sleep okay and you'll pick
yourself up and you'll learn you know
and when things are better you'll learn
for your stakes you'll start again
if on the other hand you give up you
know you give up too readily you'll
river kick yourself it's all the best of
your best in your quest it because
there's going to be I'm afraid there's
going to be a lot of people who will
fail I think the other important thing
is just not to take failure too
seriously it's something that happens to
something like 80% of all small business
people fail either go into chapter 11 or
actually go bankrupt and that's a lot of
people and some people take that really
badly and they should realize that the
important thing just to learn from it
and come back and start again and an
awful lot of you know really big you
know multi millionaires and billionaires
who've been through two or three
bankrupt companies in their lives I've
learnt from them and have come back the
stronger you know don't be embarrassed
about your failure as long as you've
tried everything you can to avoid it
don't take it too personally and don't
let people who you may respect and who
you believe know what they're talking
about don't let them tell you it can't
be done because often they will tell you
it can't be done and it's just because
they don't have the courage to train
everybody's got will and everybody's got
dreams and everybody's got aspirations
but it's only the people that really put
in the time that get there and and I
think I learned most that um despite any
any setbacks that if I just keep on
grinding I keep on working that I
usually can outwork people and and then
you know I also learned that no matter
how many times you fail it really
doesn't matter all it takes is one hit
and then everybody call you an overnight
success any time an obstacle presented
itself I used it to my advantage and
made it work and I never heard the word
know if I heard the word no it meant
maybe then it made maybe yes and that's
why I was curious about the art world in
Oprah that's a world you don't come from
when you go into those situations now
and you're mix
it up with these wealthy people and do
you find there are times you don't know
what to do you don't know the etiquette
you haven't been raised in that
environment no because I myself in any
room I am in you never embarrassed
yourself of course not you've ever
walked in and said how everybody thinks
I'm ignorant here I'm stupid but I never
I don't I don't feel ignorant right I
don't and so when you walk into a
boardroom with a bunch of guys in suits
who all went to college you're fine
yeah I mean cuz they read a bunch of
words I've lived a bunch of life well
it's true their laundry doesn't
intimidate me yeah it kind of evens us
out whether they know it and not think
people that look for great ideas to make
money you know are nearly as successful
as those who say okay what do I really
love to do what am i excited about what
I know something about you know what's
kind of interesting and compelling I'm
going to put the vast majority of my
energy attention and dollars into
building a great product or service and
put a smaller amount into shouting about
it marketing it because I know if I
build a great product or service my
customers will tell each other I look
you have to mix in some patience with
that I think serious you've got to make
sure that whatever you're doing is a
great product or service the standard is
lower for your product or service but if
you're entering anything where there's
an existing marketplace against large
and trenched competitors then your
product or service needs to be much
better than theirs it can't be a little
bit better because then you put yourself
in the shoes of the consumer and they
say why would you buy it as a consumer
you're always going to buy the trusted
brand unless there's a big difference so
a lot of times you know
entrepreneur will come up with something
which is only slightly better and it's
it's not you can't just be slightly
better it's got to be a lot better don't
necessarily think that you have to have
the homerun in the huge Apple Computer
on your first start I spent a long time
in my life with skills just building
little devices for fun for fun is one of
the key things does that drives you to
think and think and think and make it
better and better and better than you
ever would if you're doing it
a company build things at first for
yourself that you would want don't allow
anyone friend family acquaintance
teachers whoever it is don't allow
anyone to tell you that what you are
dreaming for yourself and your family is
not possible it is possible don't be one
of those people twenty years from now
are going to be walking around a
nine-to-five job miserable and angry and
bitter thank you guys so much for
watching if you have your own legendary
rules that you like to share and add
value to the community then leave a
comment below and if you like this video
you want to see more subscribe to the
channel thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon self-improvement books
are like Fitness books they never work
on their own what you need is a trainer
that's Evan get the newsletter
you